hey guys I'm Greg what's your name
I'm Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy
from the channel death and terror you
should go watch that channel some
awesome list videos on there
he's also Jaime a Machado parenthesis
Jimmy on Instagram we were here once
yeah a long time ago and we watched a
video from a channel called raka raka mm
do you remember watching that with me I
remember watching that with you good
because we're gonna watch another ratta
oh no no good all right this one's
called doing extreme dares nice are you
ready Jimmy I'm ready are you sure I'm
ready I was born ready still see I hope
this is disturbing because you're so
good-looking I want you to be
traumatized because you can't just be
perfect you're so charming I hate
looking at you
yo what's up you guys we reached 3
million subscribers we lost you guys on
Instagram Instagram off for your dad's
we're doing a desert by the way Bachman
convert to spec to purchase those of the
one
Oh
take a beautiful Thursday Lindsay
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
No
[Music]
[ __ ] it up good ah let's fake let it
soak brows I'll be going now mix for 38
points
oh hi this is robot cross sweat dog
doing some fans man I'll be up in no
time
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
dress up is it getting a slideshow in
the photo with the kids in your videos
[Music]
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what is going on okay oh I don't know
they have seen this alone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh sweet
oh it's like so much fun
[Music]
[Music]
oh boy
we just have a lot of food but we had
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
go I want to be just like them one day I
think you and I should totally have a
channel like this one day you should try
we should do it if it gets views that's
what counts right you guys stink dude
holy crap 3 million subs are at that
have been growing a lot lately at the
rate I'm at I'll be there in like 20
years their stuff is totally totally
next level though it's like crazies I
think what I do is next level yeah I
like it that we I reacted to what they
did it's like the same thing it's just
as intense and just as much hard work
and dedication don't minimize what I do
it costs a lot of money why are you
looking at my lips you want to kiss me
maybe I want to kiss you too I love the
women that they get in these videos who
are so on board to do crazy stuff to get
thrown through the table at the
beginning no or even for that girl to
just pretend to eat chili do that it's
great I mean there's ways to do it a
stud man but the girl who ate [ __ ] I
don't know it wasn't real [ __ ] it can't
be can't be but it gets you I guess you
get looks real it's still implied yeah
it was pretty gross like I'd still make
out with her though if we played spin
the bottle yeah a little [ __ ] on her
face that still make out with her mmm oh
my god you wouldn't do it no I don't
think no way to do it I thought she was
cute you're a [ __ ] Jimmy the ones with
the eggs in the vodka that was real I
think that was a legit um legit thing
there yeah legit dare they did which is
cool hybrid of realism with some fake
stuff yeah I would do that to the two I
feel like it would impress a girl at a
party you know like if there was a girl
she's like I dare to drink this I think
she would be so turned on I want to
sleep with me right away this is how
women work right I believe this is what
women are drawn to you those little kids
in the video I wouldn't kids are so
lucky damn no
wonder if they realize how big it would
she like what they're part of to just
yeah I wonder they see this like they
let them see it this afterwards they
have two little kids watch violent
videos I mean you all the time so
together a part of what must be very
exciting for them I would love to be in
a rack a rack or video yeah I wouldn't
mind paying for my own ticket flying
over to where they're at just so they
could include me for one second yeah
just to smash something in my face and I
die I make them look cool make it look
cool and I'll be like well worth my time
and money I made good but like when they
do stuff like that stuck with the whole
like that the whole stunt with like 10
playing bumper cars for real ever like a
blast yeah yeah it looks freaking fun I
would love to do that I would love to do
that except I wouldn't I would want to
drive like a Mini Cooper had have
another person be in a Hummer and then
go toe-to-toe with him ooh sounds
freaking interesting that sounds really
interesting yeah how crazy would be if I
survived that guaranteed at least 50
they got set on fire that look really
dangerous cuz I'm like he has a sweater
on oh you must have something under did
you see how they cut of you're fast
though yeah yeah they must have put him
out right away
that looks fun still dating looking like
second-degree burns from that Iraq Iraq
oh you guys are hilarious and violent
and perverts I love you guys love you
Rach a reckless subscribe to the real
rejects if you work just as hard Jimmy
death and terror is the channel with
some great list videos on there and
their channels growing we should go
check them out my values I find out why
interesting stuff you got to be more
specific than that didn't you learn
anything from sales class no I didn't
you didn't take sales in high school I
know unfortunately every kids are sales
in high school he's also Jimmy a Machado
on Instagram go follow him there you
know Jimmy I want to look at your photos
real quick all right here photos did you
even get that yeah just made a funny BJ
joke and it wasn't even caught on camera
cuz the camera cut whatever we're done